I take criticism really well no you
don't what suppose to me don't worry
young Arianna you didn't get the lead
role in Nickelodeon's victorious but
you'll go on to star in salmon CAD
eventually you'll have an incredible
music career and even get to sing with
Stevie Wonder we all have to start
somewhere your role as the adorably
clueless cat was a great beginning but
just between us we still think you were
robbed of this lead role ariana grande
isn't the only Disney Nickelodeon star
who missed out on a career defining role
luckily these celebrities don't let
setbacks stop them from reaching for the
stars
here are the Disney Nickelodeon actors
who got robbed of a leading role really
you can't think of one thing that you
like about me I like when you're sad
ariana grande on Nickelodeon's
victorious ariana grande played the
adorable ditzy bubbly drama queen Cat
Valentine
she's known by her catchphrase because
she gets easily offended we all know
what a mega superstar ariana grande
turned out to be since Victoria's first
debuted in 2010 so why wasn't she cast
as the lead in the show Nickelodeon must
have realized their mistake because they
created a spinoff of the show with the
title role for Ariana's character this
show was called Sam and Kat this series
was a crossover connecting the show
iCarly
and victorious after seeing Ariana blow
up in the music industry
you got a wonder if Nickelodeon regrets
not casting her in a bigger role in
victorious luckily it all worked out for
Ariana in the end Liz Gillies
speaking of victorious there's another
actor who was also left out of the
spotlight we're talking about those
super talented Liz Gillies who's played
the role of Jade West on the show she
was known as the pretty sassy and
sarcastic character but even though she
played a bad girl on Victorious Liz is
actually super sweet in real life
liz has shown major support for the
anti-bullying movement she said she had
a group of friends who were total Mean
Girls they thought bullying would make
them more popular
thinks it's important to teach kids how
to deal with bullying by helping them
find an outlet like sports or art Liz
seems like the perfect actress to star
in victorious she would have been the
perfect role model for young girls
Sabrina carpenter Sabrina carpenter
played the role of Maya Hart
Riley's loving but rebellious best
friend in Girl Meets World
she was the sidekick in the show but she
stole every scene she was in hi I'm Maya
you're really cute we should hang out
sometime
well she could have been cast as the
lead she was happy with the character
she got to play in an interview
Sabrina talked about how she landed the
role of Maya after a bunch of auditions
she said playing that character will
always be one of her favorite
accomplishments in life
she said Maya was a deep character with
so many layers to her Sabrina was
constantly learning new things about her
character which was never boring
Victoria Justice before landing the lead
role in victorious Victoria Justice took
a passenger seat role on Zoey 101 in
this show Victoria played the role of
Lola Martinez Zoey's best friend and
roommate I know it was a good actress
and I know I'm awesome they must have
seen something in Victoria during her
time as the leading lady's sidekick
because she went on to star in
victorious Victoria likely had to prove
herself on zoey 101 before moving on to
her own leading role when reflecting on
her time on the show Victoria said that
zoey 101 was such a big part of her life
she said she has memories with the cast
of the show that will last a lifetime
while we know that no one can replace
Zoey
we can all see that Victoria was star
material from the beginning Ashley
Tisdale
Ashley Tisdale almost didn't get the
role of Sharpay Evans in the High School
Musical movies Disney executives did not
think she could pull off the Mean Girl
role because of her performance on The
Suite Life but she proved everyone wrong
I've been in 17 school productions and
how many times have your compositions
been selected
this would be the first while she wasn't
the main protagonist in the first movies
she went on to star in her own spin-off
Shar Peis fabulous adventure Ashley
showed everyone what it is to grab the
spotlight
sterling night sterling night audition
for the lead role of Troy Bolton in High
School Musical but was denied the role
as we all know Zac Efron got the part
sterling was totally bummed because it
seemed like Zach was booking everything
not sterling audition for luckily Zach
didn't get the role of Chad Dylan Cooper
in sunny with a chance we can't imagine
anyone but Sterling playing that part
Zac Efron yes that got the lead in high
school musicals but he knows what it's
like to lose a part sac opened up about
the worst audition of his life when he
went out for the live-action role of
Peter Pan he was only 15 and he had just
come from doing the play Peter Pan but
stage acting is a lot different than
acting on-screen he was way over the top
in his audition he was jumping around
and shouting which is too much for the
camera the casting director interrupted
him and asked if he'd ever done this
before and the short answer was no she
invited him to leave
it was soul-crushing for Zach he said he
kind of wept about that one luckily Zach
was able to bounce back and redeem
himself in high school musical song
can you imagine what he would have
missed out on if he had given up after
the Peter Pan audition that would have
been tragic which Disney Nickelodeon
character is your favorite and why tell
us in the comments thanks for watching
the things be sure to subscribe to our
channel to be the first to see our
latest videos and while you're at it
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
see you around
[Music]